una nueva noche de tensión y
enfrentamientos con la policía a quien
que no sea en wisconsin tras una
actuación policial que dejaría en estado
crítico a otro joven afroamericano
robots hombre quien está en el hospital
ahora mismo y que ha creado indignación
inmediata aquí en estas calles
vimos saqueos de comercios incendiaron
vehículos y se enfrentaron a la policía
pero lo que sucedió anoche es importante
analizar pues no lo hemos visto en
confrontaciones como las de por la
nómina police desde la muerte de georg
floyd en todo el país hemos visto
agitación social enfrentamientos con la
policía pero ayer la presencia de
milicias aquí en estas calles para
proteger comercios ha dado incidentes en
muy graves como la muerte de dos
personas yo en primera persona les puedo
contar lo que vi con mis ojos anoche y
es un joven de 17 años su nombre es que
el waterhouse se acercaba a la policía y
les pedía asistencia médica y lo que
después nos daríamos cuenta es que había
disparado a un manifestante que le
agredió cayó en el suelo lo vemos en
imágenes y le disparó causándole la
muerte pocos minutos después la policía
recogió el cuerpo de la víctima y vimos
tensión constante durante toda la noche
sin duda estamos ante una situación
muy compleja y vamos a ver cómo va a
evolucionar es de esperar que esta noche
tengamos tensión la policía está
acordonando esta zona por posibles
concentraciones más tarde sin duda eeuu
vive una tensión constante de distintos
puntos y ahora el foco es aquí en el
estado de wisconsin